O
CON CAWTHORN PENGRE SETTING TS N
HIM FOLLOWG CONTROVERS
E HMANMB
AN PRESUMABLY RE
LET'S BRING IN THEO-R
IF OFISTCNAGOLDBERG.
YOU E , OT THINK
ASNG,
A LEGATIONS ARA VERY
MYN,OUT REMIND
HO I AT THE NEXT TRUMP O IN
THE I THE INTERESTING
N BECAUS CATS FROM THA
CRACKING DOWON TTER THAN NO E IC
SHOULD, BUT EYT CRACK
DOWNWHT PES L  TO IS THAT
FROE ICAN CONGRESS ME
BASE ABOUT WHA SAID.IN A SORT O
IOTHARS  AND HAVIN
CAUSE SOME SKEPTICISM, RIGHT?
BUT THE BASE HEARD THIS AND
AND SO THEY HAD TO PUT IT OUT.
YW, PAUL GOSAR OR
MARJORIE SPEAKING
TOTE SUPRECIS
OUTH DID SAME
PRESSURET ITNE TWEETED TO SAY, E
LY THINGS YO
KEVINTHY, THE
HIS COF ORGIES ANDBILITYCCUSE
FOR JANUARY 6t
THAT'ST IT.
S ARE VERY, VERY LUCKY
THEY HAVTH AT THEI
YOU CAN SEE INIF DIFFERENT CONXF
ESR
BUT RIGHT NO I THINKINMcCAERATI
THE ASSUMPTION THAHESN'TG .
NORTH DAKOTA SENATOR NEF ,
DONALD TRUMP'S CFOR AD
DIRON
AHIS IS NOT THEDIENSKYY BACK
CAUSED THE FIRST IMPEAME
S NELL
IN THE MIDDLE OF A
HE CRAME I KNOW
DI OBIDEN.
DOESHOULD REVE IT.BU IA WAR CRI
DON'T EXPECT THAT'S RIGHT NO
HINOW, REVEAL
HAS IT.ANY THAT HE
>> I MN, SAID THIS AT THE SUSAC
HAD LED LESSOND WAS THAT HE CA
T H IT AND NOWS  IT.
>> THIS IS HUGE
HEADACHE FOR KEVIN CME
E THINGSRE NOT NALD TRUMP TRUMP
PRICED INTO THE DONALDN WAY.
T
PAY A HIGHERN DONALD
TRUMP DOES. THESE CLASSIC O KW,
TALK UNLESS YOVE ALL
FOOL.
Y UF WAS A DUMB,EFENSIBLTHAT DA.
INNUENDO, SAYING THE MOSINW IN
CALLY HEN FODO, IS JUST FROM A
D MORASE.
AND THE SHOC ABOUT
THIS I THINKT IT WOULDE IN TICAR
F RATHER THA
LET TRUMP GET AWAY WITH THE
STUFF THAT HE SAYS.
>> YOUANO RUBIO
OUT-TRUMTRUM IT  WORK.
>>ANNON AN HTRIED TO SEED THE R
PART TRUMPIKS
D THEY'VE NEL FAIL